hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester this this is
Game two of the rapid first game was won
by dinghy after that blunder by eleven
that rook to c7 idea now it's 11 with
the white pieces and he he definitely
should equalize otherwise if if he
doesn't he it's gonna be much harder to
get back into the blade section of the
match since in Boise you only get two
points for a win and in rapid it's four
points for a win without further ado
let's check it out eleven with the white
pieces opens with c4 the English opening
is on the board with Knight f6 Knight to
c3 and c5 Knight to f3 and the knight to
c6 is the four Knights of the English
with d3 and d5 now C captures Knight
captures and now III the so called a cup
of Blanco variation where the bishops
will be developed to D 2 and E 2 with
Bishop to e7 and Bishop to e2 preparing
the castle we have castles by black and
Bishop to d2 so you have this sort of a
sort of a passive setup but it's it's if
it works it works and also lemon has to
play something at least a little bit
peculiar as he needs to get a
complicated position and try and win
this game we have Bishop to e6 by dink
and now a three with a5 stopping before
and now there are games were rook to see
one error or castles were played but
Queen to c2 is a new move in the
position so already as a move 10 we have
a completely new game we have Knight to
be six avoiding the trade and now b3
taking away some very important squares
from the Black Knight with f5 grabbing
more space on the Kings side and now
Bishop to c1 here 11 before deciding
where he's going to castle once the
Riemann over this Bishop over to this
diagonal we have Bishop to f6
ding also prepares the counter this
Bishop adds additional protection to the
e5 pawn the shop to b2 and now even g5
biding and this really discourages 11
from Castle egg on the Kings side so we
have Knight back to d2 not allowing the
Knights to remain a target Bishop back
to g7 opening up the F file for the rook
and
just h3 we have Queen to e7 developing
the Queen connecting rooks and now g4
still waiting to see what what dings
plans are on the kingside here he plays
f4 planning to open up the center with
FF captors on e3 but now just Knight DT
for offering this F captures and ether
on e3 but for the moment the ding just
Waits he goes Knight to d5 and here
finally 11 cap decides to Castle
queenside and of course it's a it's a
castles of opposite sides we're going to
have a nice race who can attack quicker
where and here it seems like you could
go for this pawn but even if you do for
example captures captures oh sorry white
will not recapture immediately first you
just remove one of the attackers of the
e3 Square and only after there should
recaptures now you captures here and
while you are able to mess up White's
pawn structure here doesn't really
matter because those are very useful
squares for white and the white will not
have any problems here so instead we
have a 4 by ding just attacking on the
Queen side you do want to open up the a
file as soon as possible before and now
why ding decided for this line we have
night D captures on b4 so a nice night
sacrifice which gives him a lot of play
and it's not really all that big of a
sacrifice since he does grab to her
important points for the piece so it
captures and now before we capturing
first a3 pushing the bishop further back
Bishop to a1 and now Knight captures and
b4 with an attack on the Queen Queen to
b1 and now even f3 so making the the
bishop really a useless piece with
Bishop to f1 disconnecting Levin's rooks
and now rook the ASX preparing rook to
b6 or c6 depending on what 11 plays as
the Queen and King are sold well in
committee conveniently placed on b1 and
c1 and here 11 goes for he maybe should
just start running away with his king
somewhere but he tries to Knight
captures on g5 which is interesting if
the Queen actually captures you can
eliminate the b4 night and with the
before night out of the way you should
be ok but here instead of
just capturing ding plays a - there was
even a more powerful idea just night to
a to wit check it's really strong
because after night captures you've
freed the B file for your rook you go
rugby six attack the Queen and after the
Queen moves now Bishop to b3 and now
white completely falls apart you don't
have a good square for your queen let's
see if Quincy three just rook to c6 wins
the Queen if you move the Queen to be
one you just pick up the rook open up a
discovery to the Queen there really are
no good move Syria if you move the Queen
just Queen captures and g5 now you grab
the piece and you use you just have a
much better position without actually
sacrificing anything so on Knight to e2
also very nice move but okay being has a
different idea dingos for a two attacks
the Queen Queen to b2 and now look at
the b6 now threatening some very nice
discoveries like Knight captures on d3
so first we have Knight captures on e6
asking well now it wouldn't be all that
big of a deal if Knight captures and d3
it would just be giving up too much
material so first thing recaptures on e6
and now Queen the a3 getting the Queen
out of the way we have looked at e8 as
11 wiggled out now a bit out of the
position but ding brings another piece
into the attack and now 11 plays rook to
d2 he wants to bring the rook over here
just to help out with with all this
attack on the Queen side but for a month
the d3 point is under attack so you
might want to just hide your king
however if this doesn't work here ding
missed his opportunity for a very nice
idea but you know you are comfortable in
your home you know or in a bar or in a
library so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the mood editing mist
here while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on finding a
move this time with the blush of the
back and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's Bishop to f8 just
aligns the bishop with the Queen here
and now you're threatening Knight
characters and d3 where the bishop will
just pick up the Queen so you don't have
a good reply to this if you move the
King so Knight d3 doesn't come with
check you still do it as the queen is
under attack and once the Queen moves
now you catch run if you would check the
rook cannot capture because it's pinned
you have to move the king now you play
Queen capture Sunday to you eliminate
the Queen and after rope captures you're
also gonna pick up the night here and
you just enjoy this position being up
the exchange but also with a very strong
past F pawn and even though rook h2
seems seems very ugly just f2 check King
moves and I g3 check King captures
Knight capture screen captures and now
you are up upon up the exchange of
course in a completely winning game so
Bishop to f8 the deadly but ding doesn't
want to invest too much time in the
position as it is a rapid game he plays
c5 first and now again xi is able to
wiggle out a little bit we have Knight
to e4 and now comes the Bishop to f8 now
Bishop defeat is not as potent because
just Quinta a4 gets the Queen out of
this diagonal and you don't have any any
in any good discovery so here the game
continues and 11 11th position is is
playable but very hard it is a rapidly
Mira long time here getting attacked so
it would still be very dangerous but
here 11 plate Queen to c3 and it is it
is perhaps the worst to move in the
position so feel free once again to
pause the video and try to figure out
why this is the worst move in the
position while I give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations and finding
such a well a nice reputation to this
terrible move and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's Knight
to d5 that's the point you just move the
knight with a discovery on the Queen and
rook to be one check is coming next and
that there really isn't a good reply
here if Queen c4 or something allowing
the King to move you still just go rogue
b1 check King moves and recapture son a1
you you grab a piece next you're gonna
play rook to c1 check bring another
Queen into the game there's not much
white can do here so here at level play
the Queen to c2 I prepare to give up his
queen ding of course it okay I will grab
your Queen Queen captures pawn captures
with check King captures queen and now
Knight to b4
eleven well both both let's continue the
game not not because eleven things that
he can survive this but maybe you know
maybe he's contemplating what he's going
to do in the boot section of the match
you know just maybe or maybe not he
could have done the same if the game
just ended but who knows
the point is game continued even though
black is completely winning here black
his upper queen we have Queen to b3 with
Czech Bishop to b2 and now look the AAA
to preparing to bring the rook over to
a2 we have Knight to c3 preventing that
but now e for we have g6 by 11 Bishop to
g7 and now d4 capture sincere for ecad
force on d4 and now comes Bishop
captures on d4 and it was in this
position on move 39 that 11 are on
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you are down Queen
and of course if the bishop is captured
just Queen to c2 is mate as the rook
controls the h-file so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it eleven more most
definitely did not and this brings him
down to eight points so as I went in the
rapid section is worth four points lemon
is now down eight points in the match
and if he wants to equalize the match
and go into tiebreaks he's gonna have to
win all the boys games so as blitz games
are two points per game you have to win
all four to equalize now with ding and
that's just well very unlikely but but
who knows anything can happen so once
again I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Proctor Shakur Mario and
sinasohn Pollock [ __ ] for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice tournament checking up on your
very nice suggestions and of course
continuing the next big saga thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day